- Comme adolescente, Florence
Tremblay-Gagnon a été suivie
à l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine
pour des troubles alimentaires.
Elle ne s'étonne pas
des problèmes déclenchés par
l'isolement au printemps 2020.
FLORENCEGAGNON
- Quand je pense aux
adolescents, ils se sont
retrouvés tout seuls avec
leurs bibittes. Quand on a
la vulnérabilité du trouble
alimentaire, on va chercher
un moyen qu'on a l'impression
d'avoir le contrôle, c'est
notre alimentation, c'est
le sport, c'est ci, même si
au fond, on perd le contrôle,
réellement, on n'a pas
le contrôle, absolument pas,
mais c'est comme ça
qu'on se sent.
- Le nombre d'adolescentes
hospitalisées pour des troubles
alimentaires a bondi de 60 %
depuis le début de la pandémie,
selon une étude de
l'Institut canadien
d'information sur la santé.la s.
MARIANNE LEFEBVRE,
nutritionniste
- Le 60 % était chez les filles
principalement de 10 à 17 ans.
Donc, une jeune femme, par
exemple, pourrait avoir pris
du poids pendant la pandémie
et vouloir perdre du poids
de façon malsaine ou de façon
drastique, que ça soit
en se faisant vomir,
en prenant des laxatifs.
- La même augmentation
a été mesurée au CHU Sainte-
Justine, avec trois pics
d'hospitalisations au cours
des deux dernières années.
entation des visites
en clinique externe et aussi
des cas les plus graves.
Dr OLIVIER JAMOULLE, pédiatre en
méd. adolescente CHU Ste-Justine
- On ne l'a pas vu venir, puis
ça a commencé assez vite.
Dès le mois de mai 2020,
on a vu quelque chose qui
se passait avec l'augmentation
des troubles alimentaires.
De nouveau, maintenant,
depuis le mois de janvier,
on est encore dans une phase
où il y a beaucoup de jeunes,
malheureusement, qui viennent
encore avec des problèmes de
cet ordre-là. Dont,
ça n'a pas dérougi, je dirais.
Les hospitalisations
sont encore nombreuses.
On tourne à peu près autour
de 16-18hospitalisés,
alors qu'on devrait tourner
plutôt autour de 10-12.
- Et ce n'est pas quechez les j.
L'hôpital Douglas de Montréal
a vu bondir le nombre de cas,
également.
Dr HOWARD STEIGER, chef Institus
- Un grand nombre de personnes
atteintes d'un trouble de
l'alimentation ont l'âge adulte
aussi. Je peux dire que...
le nombre de requêtes
pour de l'aide qui vient
à notre programme est
aussi au 60 %.
- Florence était justement
suivie à l'hôpital Douglas
par l'équipe du Dr Steiger.
- En 2020, je sortais
de traitements,
d'une hospitalisation.
On est tombé en virtuel, mais
ça a été beaucoup d'ajustements,
puis... moi, ça m'a affectée
aussi. Je faisais beaucoup,
beaucoup trop d'exercice.
Ça pouvait être 40 km
par jour... de course.
Oui. C'était... inhumain.
- Face à la vague,
le soutien en virtuel permet
d'aider un plus grand nombre
de patients à domicile et
redonne à plusieurs les repères
perdus avec la pandémie.
Le traitement des troubles
alimentaires peut être long.
- On va sortir d'une pandémie
qui... atteignait la population
au niveau physique, puis on...
j'ai l'impression qu'on va
sortir avec une société malade
au niveau de la santé mentale.
- Florence dit qu'elle va mieux.
Elle travaille en santé mentale
et sait que les besoins
sont grands.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Mon